[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui c'est marrant parce
que même si ça fait pas longtemps qu'on
est ensemble j'arrive pas à croire que
ça fait trois mois alors qu'on dirait
des années quand tu es sûr c'est sûr
mon bébé depuis le jour où j'ai vu ton
visage qui me sourit gardez-la pour la
vraie demande la vraie demande demain
soir à la fête du nouvel an c'est une
blague je pense que ça vaut mieux de me
laisser tomber la veille du mariage de
ma sœur
je peux pas inviter le premier venu
ramasser dans la rue
j'habite ici non c'est moi qui habite
ici
c'est pas normal
ça paraît fou mais ma sœur va se marier
et mon ex devait être mon invité je peux
quand même pas y aller toute seule je
peux vraiment pas non bien sûr je dois
vraiment avoir l'air d'une folle non non
pas du tout
oui faudra que je parte à 20h
merci merci
[Musique]
mais il est sympa je voudrais savoir
comment vous êtes rencontrés je dois
dire que cette rencontre a été plutôt
inattendue le début d'une
un très beau discours monsieur
finalement ça a été très facile
[Musique]
keep keep mais c'est lui qui ne me
regardez pas j'en ai aucune idée mais le
nouveau clip est sexy
et après il va demander en mariage un
top model il ne m'aime pas si il est si
amoureux d'elle qu'est-ce qui vous est
avec toi ce soir
je vous ai vu j'ai ressenti une chose
que j'avais encore jamais ressenti et
moi j'ai besoin de faire ce qu'il est le
plus juste quand l'univers vous offre un
cadeau on ne dit pas non
si tu veux pas appeler ça le destin
appelle ça coup de bol coup de chance
mais moi là je dois faire un choix
[Musique]
il a écrit que c'est fermé
un inconnu au mariage de ma sœur est-ce
que j'ai l'air de tout prévoir à
l'avance
[Musique]